à la soirée va bien se passer et
détendez vous je suis ravi de vous voir
bon c'est un peu hypocrite de ma part je
suis content d'être parmi vous content
d'être accueilli par le tedx des arts et
métiers je vous demande d'applaudir
l'équipe qui s'étonnaient du mal depuis
un an comme ils l'ont dit tout à l'heure
ravi d'être parmi vous pour vous parler
de progrès progrès progrès sus de
progrès 17 des fossiles et quand tu fais
un truc en latin comme ça déjà le
progrès mais surtout parlé des sources
d'inspiration du progrès qui oscille
elle aussi entre nécessité ou
fascination et finalement entre
progression parfois même régression est
la question que je vais vous poser dans
ce one man show de la conscience si je
puis dire c'est doit-on nécessairement
progresser mais avant cela étant donné
que je fais un peu moins de mal que je
suis concentriques et narcissique je
vais un peu parlé de moi alors je suis
né à alger j'ai grandi à marseille je
suis chauvin handicapés binational
musulmans bref je suis dans la merde
non plus sérieusement j'ai grandi à
marseille et c'est à l'âge de 17 ans
comme un diagnostic est atteint d'une
rétinopathie pigmentaire une
dégénérescence progressive de la rétine
est ce à ce moment là que j'ai appris
que j'allais perdre la vue
progressivement l'on m'avait mis dans un
institut pour jeunes aveugles qui
s'appelait l'arc en ciel
et j'ai fait des études de longues
études j'ai d'abord étudié la
philosophie
ensuite j'ai étudié les langues j'ai eu
un master en stratégie et un master of
science en ingénierie financière
j'ai même pu travailler dans des grands
groupes et tout ça c'est une forme de
progrès que j'ai découvert roussin de
moi même et j'ai appris que finalement
chacun d'entre nous est doté d'une
capacité phénoménale de résilience et de
trouver des stratagèmes pour pallier un
manque pas d une déficience naturel
comme quoi la nature est bien faite et
ça c'est un progrès aussi bon j'attends
toujours le progrès médical
la génétique et donc cette progression
je n'ai vécu différemment que votre
progression de tous les jours que votre
relation au progrès puisqu'il ya
plusieurs types de problèmes les progrès
social progrès technologiques le progrès
économique et le progrès moral et dans
toutes les dimensions notre société sur
l historique philosophique économique on
retrouve le progrès déjà à l'époque
parce qu'on va faire une petite
digression chez nos amis les grecs se
crêper déjà le chignon oui c'est tous
pythagore et thales enfin quoique de nos
jours j'ai posé la question à mon petit
neveu jeudi du col et thales et m'a dit
oui c'est le cousin de sang beaucoup
d'encre a good boy je fous là joomla
déjà à l'époque il y avait un grand
débat entre deux modes de pensée deux
types de pensée de paradigme certains
très ésotérique voire religieux qui
pensaient que finalement le progrès
n'est qu'une forme de décadence et que
l'humanité est voué à son échec à sa
propre disparition qui pensaient que
l'homme mais n'est dans les cieux ou
dans l'eau l'un vous dans les grandes
religions monothéistes dans le paradis
et qu' il doit être voué à son échec
dans cette forme de progrès qui n'est
qu'une recherche l'oise il en fait du
luxe et du gain de temps et une autre
forme plus moderne
je passe donc tous les auteurs comme
bécotte diderot etc qui ont amené les
différents cycles pdi le mouvement des
lumières et qui pensent que l'humanité
doit progresser et qu'à force de
progresser à l'attendre à son idéal
à travers cette ambivalence et on va la
retrouver tout au long de l'évolution
des différentes civilisations
j'ai voulu aujourd'hui vous
soulever quelques questions la question
qui porte sur notre façon d'inspirer le
progrès est ce que le progrès résident
de notre nécessité ou à ce qu' il réside
plutôt dans notre fascination de notre
curiosité et sera toujours un peu
oscillé entre les deux ans nécessité
nécessité de soigner des cités de guérir
mais on voit aussi cette ambivalence
existe encore parce qu'il ya des
maladies qui ont disparu de notre
contrée civilisé entre guillemets mais
qui existe encore dans d'autres pays
plus complexe avec des développements et
des systèmes productifs qui ne sont pas
évolué comme on le pense nous de notre
point de vue un point de vue et il ya
d'autres formes de progrès qui sont
beaucoup plus avancés dont les nouvelles
technologies souvenez-vous notre cher
ami disparu
vc the revolution c'est vrai c'est une
révolution
et c'est ce qui m'a permis moi dans mon
parcours d'évoluer rapidement puisque
j'utilise d'autres zones de mon cerveau
qui chez vous sont comment dirais-je
accaparé par votre vision
c'est pour ça que je n'ai pas utilisé de
support aujourd'hui aujourd'hui vous
êtes comme moi vous êtes mal voyantes
d'ailleurs tiens on va être un alibi
revanche le lendemain et finalement
cette ambivalence on la retrouve dans le
progrès scientifique dans le progrès
médical et dans le progrès social aussi
on a eu les coeurs les congés p les
vacances etc
pour avoir plus de temps mais finalement
ce temps on ne consacre pas comme ces
grecs à l'époque qui dans l'antiquité
passé le temps à contempler et cette
contemplation
justement nous fait basculer de cette
nécessité vers cette fascination est
l'homme de tous temps et fasciné par les
cieux par exemple on a eu car
aujourd'hui on a interstellar d'imaginer
thales socrates pythagore et platon en
train de manger des poids coq des pop
corn devant interstellar ce serait une
syncope
et finalement cette fascination a
toujours donné lieu à un progrès
aujourd'hui nous l'avons vu avec les
deux présentations précédentes un
progrès quand même incommensurable qui
va de plus en plus vite et au fond de
cette volonté de progresser qu'est ce
qui est vraiment l'inspiration toujours
à travers cette même ambivalence cette
opposition entre ces deux courants de
pensée certains qui ont une vision assez
manichéenne entre le bien et le mal les
gentils et les méchants vont dire nous
progressons mais la technique perverti
loeb
pourquoi parce que par exemple facebook
il a été créé ce réseau social pour
communiquer entre les universités pour
permettre aux chercheurs de communiquer
aux avis de communiqué donc il y avait
une sorte de cercle vertueux
aujourd'hui vous voyez des postes j'ai
mangé des camps flex on prend son plein
en photo le danger c'est de se retrouver
dans une réalité virtuelle justement
mais la réalité virtuelle existe de
manière digitale
nous ne sommes pas des machines jusqu'à
preuve du contraire
si l'on prend tous les romans
d'anticipation comme ceux d'isaac asimov
ou même de george orwell et qu'on les
transpose aujourd'hui bien soit ils sont
visionnaires soit une boule de cristal
et finalement ça nous ramène à nous
interroger sur quelle est la véritable
source de progrès moi je pense
personnellement et ça c'est mon histoire
personnelle que je vais vous raconter
que c'est nous le progrès nous sommes
source de notre propre progrès toujours
dans l'ambivalence
certains pensent que l'homme et dieu et
que dieu et loeb
d'autres pensent le contraire justement
que toujours de manière primitive nomme
temps à sa destruction
mais dans mon cas personnel quand j'ai
commencé à perdre la vision
progressivement
je me suis dit mince je me retrouve
démuni face aux autres ils voient bien
alors j'ai dû naturellement je ne sais
pas comment je les fais mais j'ai
découvert naturellement que avoir entre
guillemets le cul entre deux chaises
entre le monde des voyants et le monde
des malvoyants me permettait d'avoir une
vision objective une vision extérieure
qui me permettait de questionner mon
environnement et 2 contres
de manière différente de manière
beaucoup plus stratégique d'ivoire
tactique comment fonctionne
l'environnement et j'ai dû trouver des
stratagèmes où débute jeudi avec une
lampe à l'école je mettais au premier
rang et moi appelé à la teinte toute ma
scolarité de ces théories
c'était henry et finalement je ne
pouvais plus lire j'ai justement
utiliser ce type de logiciel qui m'a
fait découvrir que la mémoire auditive
et de manière infinitésimale beaucoup
plus puissantes et beaucoup plus ancrée
dans le temps que la mémoire visuelle et
à force d'écouter les cours de ne plus
pouvoir lire le tableau je me suis mis à
développer une sorte de mémoire
hypermnésique et contraire de l'amnésie
et de là je me suis bien à développer le
noir spatiale et j'ai un excellent sans
augmentation c'est quand même paradoxal
et c'est ce que j'appelle une vision
topographiques j'ai développé une vision
topographiques
je deviens vision parce que voir est une
action mécanique qui dépendent des yeux
c'est très mécanique le cortex visuel
primaire la vision est inversée on voit
alors que percevoir c'est l'ordre du
discernement sa demande de l'abstraction
sorte de voyage astral
bon j'ai pas fumer du chantre à un ample
et cette vision topographiques j'ai pu
la développer grâce à une discipline qui
a beaucoup compté dans mon évolution
personnelle mais je vais pas vous en
parler on va regarder ça et vous allez
être très surpris je pense
[Musique]
involontaire les arts martiaux ont guidé
toute ma vie j'ai d'abord commencé par
la boxe française
ensuite j'ai fait du judo de l'aïkido et
j'ai même pratiqué le sabre japonais le
maniement des armes et bien sûr la boxe
anglaise et ça c'était un gala qui a eu
au mois de janvier contre un ancien
champion du monde des mi-lourds
alors vous savez comment il fait
découvrir aux pas venir alors forcément
quand je boxe mes adversaires et sunrise
aux malfrats paisible des handicapés
alors je répéte asie tu peux y aller je
prends des poteaux des buts des
trottoirs vas-y ils veulent pas mais on
va prendre la volonté un tien pierre
dumont devient mon ami je vous montre
l'expérience barre a plus beaucoup plus
parlant l'être humain doté de sens on
est d'accord je suis pas daredevil et
pour les sens sont interconnectés dans
notre cerveau il est réparti comme une
commune centrales nucléaires de façon et
plus ou moins équilibrés mais la vue est
un sens qui consomment beaucoup
d'énergie à partir du moment où je ne
vois plus il me reste pas louis cd pas
vrai c'est la conscience en fait c'est
la logique si pierre parle et il est là
je crois qu'il est là s'il parle
sa voix est ici on est d'accord allez
ici donc il va rester alphabet et sa
tête est ici donc je n'ai plus besoin
d'avoir cette précision
sa tête est ici ses bijoux de famille
sont vers la
merci pierre finalement cette expérience
vous pouvez expérimenter vous même avec
vos vaudois avec votre sens du toucher
quand vous rentrez chez vous le soir
qu'il n'y a plus de lumière vous avez
tout cet instinct d'allumer la lumière
pour rentrer votre clé dans la serrure
pourtant vous avez juste à mettre votre
doigt je suis sûr que certains d'entre
vous le fonds et vous pouvez trouver
directement le trou de la serrure est en
fait c'est juste se concentrer de
manière interne sur ce qui nous reste
comme ça on se comprenait handicapées en
situation de handicap pour finalement
développé une capacité à être résident
et devient finalement entre libé aussi
valide qu'un valide n'est pas normal
parce que la normalité c'est pas une
norme
tout ça pour vous dire finalement que
pour moi le progrès c'est l'inspiration
que nous avons et que nous devons avoir
de ce qu'est pour nom de l'humanité
c'est quoi l'humanité c'est la race
humaine
c'est vivre en société ivre de manière
collégiale et c'est le capitalisme néo
libéralisme tout ça c'est pas forcément
des notions moderne
de tout temps il ya eu des nécessiteux
comme des nantis
le progrès technique de progrès
technologique et médical doit permettre
à l'humanité d'avancé mais doit surtout
lui permettre de se questionner sur son
comportement
aujourd'hui on à l'émergence de nouveaux
mouvements comme la décroissance
l'innovation frugal ou encore le
biomimétisme
d'ailleurs je vous invite à aller voir
et lire des conférences de idrissa gana
grand trip le docteur émérite qui parle
justement de la renaissance de
l'humanité à travers cette nouvelle ère
technologique mais la renaissance va
être la recherche de l'idéal de
l'humanité et non pas la prolongation
votre humanité c'est ça la grande
question qu'on doit se poser est ce que
nous sommes voués à vivre de manière
éternelle
google + les gaffes investissent des
millions de dollars des milliards de
dollars sur la vie éternelle pouvoir
remplacer nos organes etc
moi je serais le premier heureux si on
remplace les yeux et pas souci mais
est-ce que nous sommes voués à vivre
mille ans de bilan et c'est là où
finalement profondément le don
d'ubiquité c'est être partout en même
temps tout le temps vivre toutes
manières oisive
c'est un peu notre défaut intrinsèque
qui nous questionnent et qui nous dit
est ce que le progrès c'est profiter de
tous est ce que c'est juste prendre le
temps d'observer de contempler la nature
qui nous entoure et comprendre cette
nature ne pas essayer de la servir car
pour rien contre un typhon ont contre
une sécheresse et ça toute la
technologie peut nous permettre de nous
adapter mais pas de lutter contre la
nature
alors moi pour conclure je vais vous
inviter à vous interroger sur qu'est ce
qu'il peut nous permettre de progresser
en tant qu'être humain surtout dans les
temps troublés dans lesquelles vivent en
ce moment ça se trouve je vais rentrer
au bled je sais pas
donc c'est qu'est ce qui valorise
d'êtres humains est ce que c'est le fait
d'être uniforme de tous se ressembler
ouest s'est fait des trucs différents
la différence est une vertu est une
valeur forte c'est pas un obstacle
être handicapé est une richesse une
richesse parfois je vous avez du mal à
vous bandé les yeux pour ressentir
finalement le progrès c'est nous qui
devons aspirer et c'est pas lui qui doit
nous inspirer nous devons maîtriser le
progrès être son maître et passons
l'esclave et il est temps pour moi de
progresser vers la sortie et pour vous
de continuer à progresser dans cette
conférence merci beaucoup